I'm Miss minutes
it's my job to catch you up.
So let's not waste
another minute settling.
Sharpen your pencils and check this out.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
The Loki producers revealed
a bunch of deleted scenes and an entire
deleted storyline they decided to remove
from Loki Season 2,
involving a much, much bigger version
of the new Kane Multiverse war.
It would have been a completely different
storyline, way more cameo scenes,
obviously, so we'll break it down
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
We're doing episodes every week.
We're also doing the Loki
Blu ray giveaway to
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and just let me know
what you want them to do with Loki
in the next couple of Avengers movies.
careful for spoilers
for everything. On Loki.
So far
this video is mostly about deleted scenes
and storylines,
so I don't really consider that spoilers,
But currently Loki Season
two is about Loki, Sylvie, the other TVA
characters cleaning up the damage
to the timeline in the TVA
they caused in season one by killing
he who remains
and freeing the Council of Kangs
in the wider multiverse.
That was the whole idea
at the end of season one.
If you think I'm a bad way to you, meet
my variants.
See you soon.
As in the Council of Kangs
was going to show up right after that.
during the actual Loki season
two episodes,
this whole timeline is broken storyline.
They're visualizing through the machinery
behind the sacred timeline,
just saying that it's breaking down.
Basically, it can't handle
all the extra multiverse timelines
and if it does break down,
all of time will collapse, basically
causing the destruction of all reality.
So past, present and future
would start existing simultaneously,
making it way easier for them to explain
why dead characters come back in
the next Avengers movie.
Coincidence?
I think not.
We see what you're doing there.
Marvel You thought we wouldn't notice,
but we did.
but no matter what the story
was going to be, we knew that Loki season
two was going to set up Avengers 5
Kang Dynasty, Avengers 6 Secret Wars.
Loki was always going to be
at the center of all that.
But once Marvel decided
to make Kang the new Thanos Big Bad,
the next Avengers movies,
they basically started
setting up the Council of Kangs
as the next major overarching villain.
But here's where we get to
all the deleted scenes deleted storyline.
According to the Loki producers,
when they started making season
two, like a couple of years ago,
they had a completely different plan
for the Council of Kangs
and how everything would lead
into Avengers five.
the main reason why they had to change
the plot is because of the pandemic
delays, rescheduling all the movies.
So everything was coming out out of order
from what they had originally intended
Ant-Man and the WASP, Quantumania ended up
getting released before Loki season two
in originally Loki season
two would have come out first
their original version of Loki season two,
like all these deleted
storylines, would have been mostly
about the actual Kang Multiverse war.
We would have seen the actual war
going down in each episode
with the different Kang
variants fighting for supremacy.
So in Loki season two episode one, like
the actual version that we finally saw,
Loki goes on and on telling them stories,
telling about the Kang Multiverse.
War like war is coming.
We would have actually seen
that playing out in each episode.
Immortals. Rama. Turtle.
Scarlet. Centurion. Victor. Timely.
Mr. Griffin.
Dr. Doom.
Like all the others
on the Council of Kangs,
there would have been many of them, way
more than we're actually going
to see in Loki Season two.
They'll still be some king variants
that we'll see, but not nearly as many
The producers
also kind of confirmed my theory back
when the Loki Season one finale aired.
So a couple of years ago,
when the finale was first released,
Loki comes back to the TVA.
Nobody remembers him.
He sees the King's statue
in place of the timekeepers.
my theory at the time was that
the King Multiverse war
had broken out again
and all the Kangs
were fighting each other.
And at the moment
another king, like the King
the Conqueror variant was winning
and had taken over the TVA
and was using it to destroy
other timelines.
The producers pretty much confirmed that
originally they intended for the plot
to be something closer to that concept.
Loki comes back in the King multiverse.
War has broken out again.
They're in the middle of it
because the battle is happening
across all points in the timeline, past,
present and future is total chaos.
Nobody knows what to do
Then Marvel shifts
the release dates for their Marvel phase.
For Marvel Phase five movies, Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania comes out before
Loki, Season two and suddenly
it doesn't make sense for that statue
to be of Kang the Conqueror
because they wanted to seem like Ant-Man
killed him at the end of Quantumania.
then they had to change the plot
for Loki Season two and just created
the time slipping storyline and said that
Loki had time slipped in his own timeline
back to the beginning of the TVA,
and they said that
at that time he who remains,
wasn't hiding his identity.
So the statue was of him.
Like they had to find a way
to explain why this look like.
Kang I think their original idea
for Loki Season two was to introduce
that Main Kang the Conqueror variant
that we saw in Quantum Mania.
The Kang Multiverse War rages
throughout season two. We see a bunch
more of The Avengers characters
cameo the Kangs vying for supremacy.
then when Ant-Man, the WASP Quantumania
was still happening after Loki Season two,
they would explain how the Council
of Kang's Exiles that mean Kang
the Conqueror
variant to the Quantum Realm,
where Janet Van Dyne finds him
explaining how he wound up in there
because when the movie came out,
there was a lot of hand-waving, like,
why did you get exiled?
What happened during the multiverse war
like that would have happened
during Loki season two,
Then the rest of the Ant-Man Quantumania
plot picks up the way
we saw it in theaters.
so that seems like the first reason
why they changed Loki Season two so much.
Mostly scheduling.
It wouldn't have made sense
for him to disappear in Ant-Man.
The WASP Quantumania
then show up as a major villain in Loki.
Season two.
the second major reason why they deleted
all those multiverse war storylines
and scenes is because of a larger shift
inside Marvel behind the scenes,
also because of budget.
This will make sense in the second.
when Kevin Feige decided to hold that Kang
Multiverse
war storyline from season two
and save it for Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty
to do the Avengers
level version of the Kang Multiverse War.
think about it this way
If we'd actually seen the Multiverse war
going on in each episode,
it would have been cool,
would have been really awesome storyline,
way more cameo scenes, way bigger
way more epic scope way more multiverse.
Shattering consequences.
but there's no way they would have
had the money to spend on it.
They would have needed to
to actually do it right.
they decided they wanted to do an Avengers
endgame level version of the Kang
Multiverse War, which requires hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars, way
more big characters, just generally way
more people working on it
than they would have had for Loki.
Season two.
this is also one of the reasons
why they decided to turn that Iron Man
Armor Wars
TV series for Rhodey into a movie.
There's no way
they would have had the budget
to do it on an actual TV series.
So it sounds like
a lot of all these changes went down
right after Loki season one ended.
They started with this Kang Multiverse
war season two idea,
but then quickly pivoted when they decided
to use Kang as a much bigger character,
the Council of Kangs,
for the next two Avengers movies.
Marvel did not go into Loki Season
one knowing that
Kang would be the next Thanos
level villain or the Council of Kangs.
when they first cast Jonathan Majors,
they only cast him to play He who remains.
He was only written
as he remains in the script.
There were no references to Kang at all
all the Kang stuff didn't really happen
until very late in the process.
After Kevin Foggy saw the actual footage
of his performance in the Loki
finale in Marvel took a hard
turn into the Council of Kangs.
Like, well, we could actually use him
as our next overarching villain.
look.
Season two is still setting up Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty, Secret Wars,
setting up Deadpool three.
Couple other things.
Loki still very much central
to everything in this multiverse saga.
Movies like everything in Marvel,
Phase four or five and six.
but it's just interesting to see how,
like, one thing changes in the storyline
for all these different movies
has to change at the same time on a dime.
probably one of the reasons why they had
some story issues behind the scenes
in Marvel Phase four mobile Phase five,
just them changing things so quickly.
let me know in the comments
if you think they made the right call.
Saving all the Kang Multiverse War stuff,
the Council of Kangs for Avengers
five and Avengers six or would
you have rather seen that play out over
Loki Season two in a much smaller form
keep in mind
this would have actually meant using
a totally different villain for Avengers
five in Avengers six
and there aren't
a lot of Marvel characters
that are big enough that they've set up
enough that could fill that role.
the Celestials, maybe Galactus.
Maybe they would have had to introduce
Galactus way sooner.
He's supposed to be one of the main
villains in the new Fantastic
Four movie that's still coming out in 2025
before Avengers five,
so they still are doing Galactus
they're actually a bunch of deleted scenes
of Galactus in Thor, Love and Thunder.
So it sounds like Marvel was toying
with that idea of using Galactus
in a bigger way as a bigger villain
for a while before they developed
all their Marvel Phase four movies.
But here's the thing.
This actual deleted scene of Galactus
in Thor Love and Thunder is of him
fighting Jane Foster's Thor.
in it was meant to take place
after she first
got the hammer and started learning
how to use it.
Being Lady Thor,
there was a time jump during that movie
if it wasn't totally clear,
she was supposed to have been Lady Thor
for almost six months.
When Thor returns to new Asgard and sees
her for the first time, like, Wait, what?
there were a bunch of her adventures
during that period
they would have shown in a montage,
including this Galactus scene.
it sounds like at the time Kevin Feige
decided to take Galactus out of the movie
and save him for the new Fantastic Four
movie, which I think makes more sense.
Like he debuted
in the Fantastic Four comics, he's mostly
thought of as a Fantastic Four character.
this would have been a much more comedic
jokey version of Galactus.
I don't think fans would have been quite
as happy with that.
In Marvel pivoted so hard and fast
away from the Eternals movies.
They kind of relegated the Celestials to
the background of this overarching story.
At the moment, it sounds like early on
they decided against using them
for the next Avengers
movies. Like, you know what?
Maybe we'll just hold the Celestials
for a while.
you have to imagine
that version of Avengers
five would have been like
the celestial host
in Urchin, the judge returning to Earth
to judge it just wipe it from existence.
So the Avengers or the new Avengers
formed to try and stop them.
But how do you fight
giant God tier creatures?
You'd have to have the God killer armor
like it have to be the big iron Man twist
where Rhodey finds the God killer
They probably still would have done
Secret Wars for Avengers six,
but they probably would've
just made it more of an X-Men movie.
they'll still be a ton of X-Men characters
in the actual version of the movie
that we'll see in theaters, though,
But it sounds like Marvel just pivoted
into the multiverse storyline
for all these next Avengers movies
way harder.
In the original version,
it would have been quite as much
that the Council of Kangs right now
currently the Big Bad,
but they're only going to be
the main villain through Avengers five.
Marvel always planned to move past them
when they got to Avengers six.
the rumor right now is that it'll be like
a beyond type character
because we're talking about secret wars
here, like that 1980s
and the more modern version.
but the rumor is that that beyond will be
just another Kang variant
here's the thing, though. Early theory.
Would you rather actually see them
give that role to a Loki character
like make Loki the overarching antagonist
in Avengers six secret wars
and give him the got Emperor Doom's
storyline from the newer secret wars?
so it's not reversing all of Loki's
character development
he becomes the Loki who remains
so like he lives
for millions and millions of years
and it changes the way that he thinks
and he winds up
trying to save the multiverse.
But that turns him into more
of an antagonist.
So even though he's trying to save
everyone, he becomes the antagonist again.
there would be something
that Marvel would do if they wanted
to pivot away from the Kang character,
like we'd done
enough with the counsel of Kang.
We want to move past that.
Want to move
past Jonathan Majors version of Kang
Civil Wars isn't coming out to like 2027
at the earliest.
They have plenty of time
to figure that out.
all, your theories in the comments below
in my Loki Season 2 Episode 3 video
we'll post after they release it.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click Here for my Episode 3 Video.
Update the link as soon as I post that
and click here for my full Loki Season
2 Episode 2 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!